رمضان على الابواب استهلاك الطعام يتضاعف
ليصل الى اسراف بلا حدود في فتره شهر
رمضان في المنطقه من المتوقع ان تصل
مبيعات التجزئه هذا العام في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والشمال افريقيا خلال رمضان الى 66
مليار دولار وفقا لبحث جديد والتضخم مساهم
كبير في عمليه النمو اظهرت الابحاث التي
اجرتها ان المشتريات المخطط لها سترتفع
بنسبه 14% خلال شهر رمضان هذا العام بينما
من المقرر ان ينخفض الانفاق على الطهي في
المنزل بنسبه 50% عن العام الماضي على كل
حال مزيد من التفاصيل ونسبه الانفاق في
الدول العربيه في فقره بالارقام مع علاء
سرحان
في دراسه حديثه نشرتها صحيفه المدينه
السعوديه توقعت ان يصل حجم الانفاق في
المملكه خلال شهر رمضان القادم الى نسبه
44% مقارنه برمضان الماضي ذكرت الدراسه ان
50% من المستهلكين الذين استشارتهم قالوا
انهم يشترون بناء على العروض الترويجيه
اما الشعب المصري فيستهلك سلعا غذائيه في
رمضان تصل قيمتها الى نحو 120 مليار جنيه
مقارنه ب 60 مليار جنيه في الاشهر العاديه
اي نصف القيمه تقريبا هوسوا التسوق
الرمضاني يرتفع في المغرب كذلك بنسبه تصل
لاكثر من 16% خلافا لباقي اشهر السنه خاصه
على السلع كالزيت والعسل لتحضير الحلويات
ما ينعكس على ميزانيه الاسر ويتقل كاهلها
بمصاريف اضافيه معدل انفاق الاسره الارد
نيه على الطعام والشراب في حدود من 33 الى
34% وذلك بمبلغ يقدر ب
12,519 دينارا سنويا للاسره الواحده
ويتضاعف هذا الانفاق مرتين او ثلاث مرات
في بعض الاحيان في رمضان وياتي على حساب
نفقات اخرى
[موسيقى]
على كل انتظم الينا الصحفيه في قسم
الاقتصاد سمر يسعد صباحك من جديد
شهر رمضان المبارك اقترب تحدث عن توجهات
المسلمين
للتسوق في هذا الشهر الفضيل نعم سهام
بالفعل مثل ما تكلمت قبل قليل في المقدمه
هناك شركه ابحاث ريدسير سوت ابحاث سلامات
تقريبا
فشركه ردسير سوت ابحاث وسالت مجموعه من
الاشخاص في المينا ريجن منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا عانت توجهات
المتسوقين في شهر رمضان نادين خربطتي لنا
الحلقه كلها
اللي صار انه مبدئيا هنا شلون كان السؤال
الاول
طيب بدايه مثل ما قلنا في المقدمه هناك
توجهات اكثر الى
سوف يتم الابتعاد عن اللجنه السلع الفاخره
سيكون هناك توجهات اكثر لشراء هناك توجهت
لشراء السيارات هناك توجهات لشراء الاشياء
المنزليه اللي هي مو العفش يعني الاكل
تعمله
خارج المنزل توجهات الى المطاعم هذه اخبار
جيده لاصحاب المطاعم حيكون توجهات اكثر
بالاكل في الخارج 33% اكثر من العام
الماضي هناك توجهات اقل للطبخ في المنزل
مثل ما قلنا للاسف او السلع الفاخره حتى
تشهد بعض التباطؤ طبعا هاي بحسب ردسير
يعني هذه مو رايي الشخصي ايضا هناك توجه
لشراء السيارات بسبب العروض اللي حتكون
موجوده
يعني شو السر لماذا يشهد الشهر كل هذه
الخصومات هل انه شهيه المستهلكين تتراجع
ويجب تحفيزها ام ماذا
المستهلكين على الطعام بتزيد بس يمكن هو
اللي يصير انه انت عندك يسموه او فاستبل
يعني دائما الناس يحاولون شركات الاعلانات
تحاول دائما تستغل اي موسم مثل ما قلنا
سابقا
الفالنتاين مثل ما قلنا عيد العزاب مثل ما
قلنا فهو اي موسم يسوون فيه تحفيز للشراء
واللي يصير انه في شهر رمضان لانه ساعات
العمل اقل لانه ما نقضي وقت كل شويه
رايحين جايبين كوفي من المطبخ او رايحين
ناكل في مكان او رايحين نتوق حتكون عندنا
مجال او وقت اكثر بحسب الابحاث للاشخاص
حتى ينزلون بعدين يريدون يتقتلون الوقت
يقضون الوقت فيحبوني يروحون للمول ساعه او
ساعتين باليوم حتى فحيكون هناك يعني مثل
تحفيز اكثر على الشراء باستغلال هذه النقط
انه المتسوقين حيكون عندهم وقت اكثر ايضا
الاشخاص لما يكونون جائعين دائما يقول لك
لا تروح تتسوق وانت جائع لانه يصير عندك
قابليه للشراء اكثر فهاي كلها يعني نقاط
تستغلها شركات التسويق لبيع المزيد من
السلع والمواد بالنسبه لشركات
التسوق ابرز الاساليب التي تنتهجها
الشركات في هذا الشهر من
المفاجئ انه هذه السنه يتوقعون هناك عوده
للبرنسد ميديا الوسائل الاعلانيه المطبوعه
بعيدا عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يمكن ما
عدا تيك توك هو الذي سوف يستمر بانه يشهد
المزيد من التسويق على التيك توك بس هناك
يعني هذا يمكن شيء مفيد لاصحاب المحلات
يقولون اليوم ان هناك توجه اكثر
المطبوعات بالنسبه للدعاءات والاعلان
والخصومات والكوبونات اكثر منها مما اون
لاين ايضا هناك توجهات للابسه او
التطبيقات المتخصصه بالبيع مثلا تطبيق
كارفور تطبيق اوناس تطبيق
الجمعيه هناك توجهات اكثر الى هذه
التطبيقات من
اليوم المود بس انت اول ما تعرفي عن اخبار
الخصومات على التطبيقات وغيره بتخبريه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا